that's not true for density matrices here things are more interesting for instance we can describe
correlated classical states with density matrices here's an example of a density Matrix representing a classical random
bit shared between Alice and Bob they always have the same classical State Zer or one and the probability is
1/2 for each of the possibilities this is not an entangled State entanglement is non-classical but
it is a correlated state another example is connected with the notion of an ensemble of quantum states
which you can think of as a probability distribution over a finite set of quantum States in particular let's imagine that
we have M density matrices row zero through row M minus one all representing possible states of a particular system
along with a probability to draw each one if we wanted to we could compute the weighted average of these density
matrices by taking a convex comp com of them but that wouldn't actually tell us what the individual states were or what
the probabilities were what we can do instead and it's quite useful to do this sometimes is to consider a density
Matrix of the form shown here on the screen this is a state of two systems where the first system has one classical
state for each of the Alternatives and we take the weighted average of M product states where the state of the
first system is always classical and essentially labels which of the m States we have for the second
system if it's not clear exactly why we'd want to think about States like this that's okay it's just an example of
a type of correlation where the first system is always classical and the second system can be in a Quantum
State a third category of possibly correlated States is the set of so-called separable
States in simple terms these are convex combinations of product States and they essentially represent present Quantum
states where any correlations between the systems are classical correlations one way to think about
States like this is that we make a probabilistic selection for a number K and then independently prepare two
systems in a Quantum state that can depend on this choice of K what's perhaps most interesting about
states of this form is that this is actually how we Define entanglement in mathematical terms in particular entanglement is
defined as a lack of separability so if you have a density Matrix and it's not possible to express it in a form
like this then by definition it's entangled I alluded to this back in Lesson Four and here it is in somewhat
greater detail by the way it can be very difficult to figure out if a given density Matrix represents an entangled
State even with the help of a computer mathematically and computationally speaking entanglement is
actually pretty complicated I mentioned at the start of the lesson that there's a very important thing we can do with density manes and
that is to describe the states of isolated parts of systems even when they're correlated and possibly entangled with other
systems the term reduce state is often used in this context and as a simple example we'll calculate the reduced
States for the individual cubits that form an ebit to be precise let's suppose that
Alice and Bob share an ebit ALICE holds a cubbit a Bob holds a cubit B and together these two cubits are in a five
plus State and the question that we'll address is what is the state of Alice's Cubit a in
isolation of course we could ask the same question for Bob's Cubit but it's easy to answer that question once we know the answer to this
one now it might be tempting to say that we can't describe the state of Alice's cubit in isolation because it's
entangled with Bob's Cubit which might somehow forbid us from describing or even thinking about the state of a in
isolation but this is false it's true that we can't describe the state of a with a Quantum State
Vector because as we'll see it's not in a pure state but every system has a state at any given moment that can be
described by a density Matrix whether it's entangled with another system or not as a thought experiment just to help
us to see what the answer to this question is let's suppose that Bob decides to take his Cubit and travel to the stars and he's never heard from
again but imagine that somewhere along the way he decides to perform a standard basis measurement on his
Cubit well we know how to calculate the probabilities for him to obtain the two possible outcomes and we also know what
the state of a will be for each possible outcome and those things are summarized in this table in particular with probability 1/2
a will be left in the zero State and with probability 1/2 a a will be left in the one state and so as was discussed earlier in
the lesson this leaves a in the completely mix State and therefore that is the answer
to our question now you might object and say that this is dependent on the fact that
Bob decided to measure his Cubit and the assumption that he does this is part of the story that led us to this answer but
if Bob is light years away by the time that he measures nothing that he does could possibly have any influence on any
experiment that Alice might decide to perform on her Cubit otherwise we'd have faster than light
communication so Alice's Cubit is in the completely mixed state regardless of whether or not Bob
measures I should make clear at this point that the notion of a reduced State and the way that they're defined doesn't really have any dependence on relativity
or the impossibility of faster than light communication this is just a way to explain it in hopefully intuitive terms
in reality there's a mathematical definition which we'll see in a more General context in a few moments it's consistent with this answer
and coincidentally with the impossibility of faster than light communication and there's also no other
definition that could be consistent with Quantum information as we know it now let's consider reduced States in Greater
generality suppose that we have a pair of systems A and B not necessarily cubits that are together in a pure State
represented by a Quantum State Vector s again we're going to focus on the reduce state of the system a and to do
this it's going to be helpful to think about the classical states of the system B so let's let gamma be this set of
classical states of b as we've discussed before back in lesson two of the series for instance
there's a unique collection of vectors f b for each B and Gamma for which the expression of s shown on on the screen
is correct and in particular there's a simple formula for these vectors we simply multiply the vector s by the
tensor product of the identity Matrix corresponding to the system a with bra B for whatever B we're interested
in what we're doing here is basically setting ourselves up to calculate what would happen if we were to perform a